[Music]
let's go to jessica in miami what's up
jessica
hi dr john how are you
we're getting there i'm glad to talk to
you because so far today has been a
disaster but we're gonna we're we're
right in the ship today so thank you for
calling what's up how can i help of
course sure um i just moved to a
completely new city
and i'm making friends and i made
friends with a girl
and she confided in me that her husband
is abusing her
and i don't know
what to do or how to help
and so tell me about it
so i met this girl
in the dog park she seemed super super
nice and she invited me out to dinner
so i went out to dinner with her and
another girl that lives here
and basically
um we just we're all married so you know
we got into the conversation about like
our husbands and stuff
and she kind of
um she was kind of telling us that she
was like really unhappy in her marriage
and i was kind of uncomfortable because
i don't really
i didn't really know her and like i
you know i didn't really kind of want to
engage too much in the conversation
because she's kind of a stranger and and
my husband is kind of great and i didn't
want to like
you know i didn't want to like suck you
because my husband's
awesome i didn't really have anything to
contribute and then she flat out told it
told us that um
she was like manipulating her um
financially mentally and then i had just
i don't know i just had this weird like
inkling to ask the question
and i said well does he does he hit you
and she she said yes
and um then she told us that um
while she's sleeping that he raped her
while she's sleeping
and i
i just
i don't know like
i don't know what to do
after that dinner happened i um
i was outside on my balcony one night
and i saw the police roll in and i saw
them like drive kind of towards where
she lived
and i didn't really think too much of it
um because you know we live in a huge
complex a lot of people kind of crazy
here you know
and um like 30 minutes after that
happened she came to my apartment she
knocked on the door and she said that um
some one of her neighbors called the
police on her because
they heard um they heard her yelling
good for them and
that um
they came to look for her um her husband
but he wasn't there
and she just said you know um you know
the police are here and i don't know
what to do and he's not here i just i
don't know like i don't know what advice
i can offer a stranger yeah um and i i
and it honestly and i'm not trying to
you know i've never dealt with something
like this so i i don't know even how to
like react or i don't even know how to
hang out with her
right or like be there and you know yeah
um but i want to like i want to i i just
don't know like how involved do you get
in these things like
what do you say how do i protect myself
if he's like you know she there certain
things she said she has said and done
has kind of like
makes me feel like they're both a little
unstable and they both might be a little
unsafe and it makes me uncomfortable to
a certain extent but i don't want to
like isolate myself or make her feel bad
or be like a bad friend but is she even
my friend because i just met her
so number one thanks for sharing that
and um
man welcome to your new house right
yeah exactly
you may have heard me say this line
before and it sounds kind of like a line
if you will but um
uh
you ever heard me say not by your hand
but in your lap
yes so that's one of these situations
where
you were hanging out with a couple of
new friends at an apartment complex and
then somebody dropped something in your
lap that now you've got to deal with
um and
there's a couple of different facets to
this number one
you're not going to be friends with
every new person that you meet and what
i mean by friends like when i say
friends i mean like someone you're going
to tell the good stuff to and the bad
stuff too and
who hurt you and you're going to he
right it's your 2 a.m people right
we only have a few of those and but
you're also going to be a neighbor and
we're all neighbors
so this
you're in a weird spot because it feels
good to have somebody tell you all this
stuff right and i don't know what to do
with it all is that fair
yeah fair
so
you're going to have to
stop accepting stuff that you aren't
equipped to handle and you're going to
have to be very very clear about a
boundaries and b what you're going to do
next okay
so if i'm in your situation here's how
i'm gonna handle that
um
if somebody tells me something really
heavy
i will ask are you inviting me to for my
opinion are you are you asking me for
what are you asking for me when they
when somebody says like hey i'm gonna
hurt myself or hey i'm i'm being abused
whatever
um
are you inviting me into this
conversation that's the first thing so
i'm gonna like we're done with the
pleasantries there i'm
now we're in action mode okay the second
thing is is i'm going to let them know
you've got 24-48 hours to call
the non-emergency line
um of the local police department or i'm
going to call
or i am calling in 48 hours and i'll be
with you when you make your report but
you've told me some stuff that i'm not
equipped to handle and i can't let
somebody in my apartment complex be hurt
uh that's different than you know my
husband won't give me the checkbook back
and he drinks too much i mean some of
that kind of stuff is
that's i mean if they're not inviting
you into that and they're just people
are just spitballing at a bar that's
that's one thing but for me my line is
when it gets into violence
then i'm not going to have that on my
conscience
i'm not gonna have somebody in my
neighborhood who's said i'm con i'm
being hurt in the present i'm not gonna
i'm gonna do what i can at least right
that's right um and you don't have an
obligation to hang out
you don't have an obligation to say yes
you can have your boundaries too
okay does that feel weird
yeah you know what it's just
it's weird for me because i feel like i
um
i've had like the same friends my whole
entire life yeah
and i'm in this new place where i don't
really know anyone and i
since i have had the same friends my
entire life i always feel this
weird obligation to like
get involved does that make sense and
because i don't really know anything
anything else like
my friendships are very
like the ones that i have are very i
guess deep and i've had them my whole
life literally the same people
in my life my whole life
so this person like i meet this person
and i am automatically like i'm like
okay like what can i you know what can i
do to help what can i you know
how can i
even if it makes me uncomfortable yes
because
your quasi-co-dependent is that fair
yeah yeah oh yeah for sure yes don't be
you're like oh just so dismissive that's
so rude
it feels like almost like a live netflix
series you're in now
and what i need you to hear me say is
this is super visceral and super real
and it feels like oh my gosh this is
like one of those murder podcasts that
kelly listens to like it feels like i'm
in a thing now right i'm in a thing
this is real world
someone's getting beat up right across
the hall
right and so i'm going to make that
phone call and i'm going to let somebody
know i don't believe in the in the
grenade throwing in the spring you know
what i mean
um okay i'm going to i just need you to
know this is coming i'm going to let
this happen um and she can here's the
thing she can do she's an adult she can
lie
when the non-emergency police officer
comes out the detective comes out
somebody comes out to see if she's okay
the social worker whatever crisis team
they've got shows up she can lie to him
and say no i'm great everything's fine
i'm all good
so what do i do when because um
it's i told her we had another
conversation and i said listen i if i
like if you come to me and like he's
hitting you or any anything like that or
you know something happen i'm gonna call
the police because i i do feel like
this is completely over my head and i'm
you know not equipped to handle these
things
um
and i feel like since i've said that
she's kind of like pulled back a little
bit and that's her hey that's i know you
want to get
you want to her to like don't put back
keep telling me everything
you put up a boundary and your boundary
is i'm calling the cops
and then she gets to respond to your
boundary you did right okay
okay where you're going to make this
messy is if you go fishing
right yeah and i don't want to do that
but you do want to do that you know it's
just not good
yeah yeah yeah of course like inside
inside i'm like but i but i want you to
tell me but i also have my own issues
and my own family and my own husband and
i just i can't yes i i can't do it yes
and so don't go fishing
go fishing
you put up your boundaries you let her
know hey i'm a person in this apartment
complex we just met you're kind you're
nice cool
um
yeah if i hear you're getting beat up
and abused i'm calling
and here's another thing this isn't
always this is rare but there's always
another side to a story
right so you got one piece of a story
one night at a bar from somebody that
you've come to find out
maybe embellishes stuff right you said
she's a little bit like i don't know
right who knows
um so you don't know the full picture
that's why i'm calling the the
authorities and i'm gonna let them sort
this out
right um if she comes to you in the
middle of the night obviously screaming
and scared of course you call that 911.
you know all that stuff
but i don't want you getting your
self-esteem off trying to solve your new
neighbor's problems
okay and this is going to sound weird
like if you
if
like if you dated somebody a long time
and then you
start dating somebody new you kind of
you kind of started from square one
right
it's very similar to your friends you've
had the same friends for a long long
time i so applaud you what a stud for
going out and like trying to make
friends that's so rad it's the only way
to have a healthy life is to go awkward
and brisk and you risked and it went
sideways right
um it goes sideways actually somebody
can fight on you i'm going to take that
back it didn't go sideways somebody
confided in you they told you it was on
their heart and now you gotta you know
you're in the middle of it um
keep risking okay
keep reaching out to people even if it's
hard even if it's wonky even if this one
ends up you know
she didn't tell the truth or she did
tell the truth and now you're gonna be
somebody who really helped be a part of
saving her life and which is noble and
good um
but yeah don't be reliant on her and her
drama and her what feels like a netflix
show
i i can't wait to know what comes next
no you don't want to know what comes
next can call the authorities and let
them take care of it if she reaches out
to you again say what do you want me to
do with this information
how can i love you how can i support you
but i ain't but just know part of my
love and support is calling people who
know what they're doing when it comes to
this stuff
she's lucky to have you i'm glad you're
asking the right questions